Next, let's take a look at a few material optimizations.
So let's look at parent materials first of all, and this is a really nice high level
way to just optimize any kind of material what they have in your project.
So it'll really help your whole team work faster and also allow you to make sweeping
changes just by editing one material instead of a series of materials.
So a material instance works with a parent-child relationship.
So the material instance gets all the properties from the material they are linked to, and
it's the exact same workflow that many other systems use.
So you select items from the parent, pass down into the child, and then the child can
decide what we want to use.
And you can even use material instances as the start of the chain if you should want.
I never use this as it can become confusing, but it's possible to potentially not cause
any issues.
You have parent materials at the top here, and you have the building parent and the glass parent.
So as you can see, you don't really want, you want a different master material based
on the properties that you are wanting the child to inherit.
So we wouldn't have a master material that could account for a glass type opacity as
well as a solid.
So we'd make two different parent materials here, and then when you make your parent material,
you can right click on this material.
And one of the top options on the right click should be create material instance.
And then you can create various instances based on that, that parent material.
And then you can go in and change maybe just the texture that's been used on a parameter
so that you can assign a variety of different textures, which all have similar properties.
So that's a really good way to start optimizing your project when thinking about materials.
Next we have quality expression nodes.
So we can use the available switch nodes to control the functionality and quality of our
material.
So we've got a series of different switch nodes, and we'll just go through a few of
them here.
So we've got a shading path switch, which is useful for specifying what part of your
material logic should be used for the render path.
You have a quality switch, which is used when the engine's quality levels are controlling
material logic.
We have a feature level switch, which is useful when setting up material for the use on the
different devices.
And then we also have a static switch or a static switch parameter, which is used to
exclude the entire branches of your material in a base material or potentially control
through a material instance.
We also have a vertex interpolator.
So a vertex interpolator node allows for better control of the value interpolation between
the vertex and the pixel work.
So offloading the work from the pixel shader to the vertex shader is a performance win
in some cases.
So in this example, we want to title the texture in the material instance and notice the 96
instruction count, which really helps with optimizing in this instance.
And then another example, it's the same material, but with the UV tile moved to the vertex
shader from the pixel shader.
So if you check out the instruction count, it's down to 95 now.
So while it's not a huge saving, this spreads out across your projects.
If you have many, many materials in your project, those extra instruction counts can all mount
up to a huge saving.
So sometimes it's about these smaller wins that we can get when applied across a larger
project, especially if you're making a parent material into a material instances, these
will all add up into your project.
And then we'll see an example of the default versus interpolated.
So here we see the material applied to that static mesh.
And you can't really tell the difference between either one of these material types.
So it not only works with items that have their calculations done in the vertex shader,
you can try using this to offload UV tiling calculations or anything along those lines.
And you might get a lot of mileage using this approach when working with certain materials in your projects.
We've also got texture area masking.
So there are a number of different ways you can do masking.
You can either do texture masking or vertex masking.
Texture masking is using a texture to define the area that should be masked.
Whereas vertex masking uses the object's vertices to define the areas that should be masked.
So vertex masking gives a few different advantages on mobile over texture masking.
So vertex masking, there are no bound by resolution or texture maps for masks.
It also reduces instruction count by not needing to sample additional material.
And it also reduces the number of used textures, which is a massive win, especially on mobile.
So if we look at the vertex area masking, there are a number of different ways you can do the approaches.
So you can see that the instruction count between vertex area masking and your texture masking,
that you'll get different results.
And it depends what you're looking for in your projects here.
And then moving on to area masking, we have a few tips.
So when importing a mesh with vertex color, make sure to set the vertex color import option to replace.
It defaults to ignore.
So you want to make sure the vertex color will not show up there.
And then you can mix and match vertex colors and texture mask data just to make sure it keeps things consistent.
And then also talking about quality improvements.
Just lastly, on the material side, by default, materials for mobile rendering will be set up to be as cheap to render as possible,
especially if you set your project settings to mobile when opening the project to begin with.
Because of this, materials that use cubemaps might not look as good as they could.
So to fix this, you can enable a couple of different flags here.
There's actually three different flags.
So you want to use full precision, which makes the material use the highest precision level on the device.
And it offers instead of medium.
And then you've got this pre-integrated GF for simple IBL, which uses GF Lite lookup.
And then you also got the high quality reflections, which provides parallax correction on reflections
and also removes the two reflection pro blending limit.
So this will make your material a little bit more expensive to render.
So don't only use it if this is maybe the key thing in your scene or that you really want to get these extra details into your project.
So on the above image here, the reflection is on the door, as we can see it turning on and off.